Boris Johnson is a clear leadership
threat he believes he was cheated out of
leadership he sees himself as
Cincinnatus he will at some stage be
called back he believes uh sooner rather
than later he hopes uh we can talk a
little bit about how that might happen
uh Liz truss who is not the most
self-aware of politicians but even she
realizes nobody's in any Rush ever to
bring her back that ain't gonna happen
she's more a thread on the idea side
she's championing uh low taxation small
government all the rest of it I don't
think she'll get very far after all no
one has done more to discredit economic
liberalism uh for a generation unless
trust herself and we live in a era now
for good or ill of big government big
government consensus on the center left
and the center right but the ideas will
Chip Away cause Mr sunak some problem be
pressure on him but the one he really
has to worry about is Boris Johnson